[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
suite à la série reste avec nous
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup sur la perte
c'est toi j'aime le foot qui aiment le
tennis est vrai tennis ce n'était ni non
rendez le tennis alors tu peux
accueillir en tout cas d'où à rennes
c'est qui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la clé d'alès ah mais c'est un fan la
dalle mais canada parce que rappelle pas
d'être là quand même merci à la fois me
donne des cheminots bagarre
kelly
et jean baptiste tu joues et où toi
avant il paraît que tu joues et tu ta ce
qu'elle sait c'est un truc de fou
aujourd'hui art où j'étais animateur
chanteur josette ou mois avec des
mariages et comité d'entreprise qui a
toujours cru ou pas oui t'es lourd y
croire c'est une chanson de mon album
mais j'y crois
bien sûr j'y crois car c'est tellement
carton chéri que j'ai un cadeau pour toi
ce soir
regarde ce que j'ai pour toi parce que
tu es disque d'or
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors viens pas
risque de refaire
j'étais parti aux états unis en voyage
d'étude voilà après après moussa où le
nom de chicago vers les lacs vers les
lacs érié rouichi nord voilà c'est un
arrêté faisait très beau et du coup je
recharge mémé valise en soute et
joyeusement avec un tee shirt et en
chine
et avant de prendre l'avion et avant de
passer la douane nom avant de prendre
l'avion je vais peut-être je veux
toilettes pour faire du bien autant
baguette à je me coince ne s'y attendait
la merguez ou les pois chiches les
mariages malheureusement qui était sorti
dit gino la période où les profits la
merguez et labrecque fois c'est comme ça
et du foot l'avion je devais prendre mon
avion
donc je sors des toilettes des mains
comme ça non évidemment aux états unis
ça rigole pas ils me voient arriver
qu'il pense que tu as quelque chose je
parle très mal je comprends à peine ce
qui pourrait enfin il couche est obligé
de retirer mes mains et la cua lama du
coach et l amérique asie les pois
chiches et la merguez
qu'est ce qu'ils en disent du coup ils
vont fermer j'ai raté mon avis oui pour
ses juges et exhibitionnisme le temps
que ça explique j'étais coincé et vous
croyez pas
[Applaudissements]
laisse moi t'aimer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis
oh
tac tac tac qui est là c'est ayem heinz
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à ses yeux
comment on fait s'il ne répond pas nous
n'en veux pas qu'elle a ses mousses
hoskins qui s'émousse oui bah s'émousse
30 mosquées où sont les femmes
[Musique]
à
oui
[Musique]
tu danses hyper bien non donc libre mais
tu fait le moonwalk
c'est un truc de ouf
[Applaudissements]
j'entends partout
[Musique]
c'est moi
rappeur cap un nom justement de codes
cachés d'internet dont le thème ça veut
dire un truc ça veut dire quoi alors
black m j'aime le black
[Rires]
gagné
tombé
il en est
série on a une triste nouvelle
aujourd'hui puisque notre ancien chef
d'état notre ancien président jacques
chirac nous a quittés on reviendra là
dessus en fin d'émission dans tpm paix
et je vais vous dire on a choisi parce
que c'est un président qui aimait le
divertissement c'est quoi un président
vraiment on a on a l'image de lui en
train de sourire en train de se balader
en train de parler à tout le monde donc
on a décidé de revenir sur toutes les
images drôles tout ce qui était voilà de
divertissant on voit on reviendra sur
les guignols j'ai commencé t pmp l'année
dernière et ça fait des rythmes de vie
de tarés en fait c'est à dire que je me
lève à 4 h 45
et je me couche il est 23h minuit et je
fais ça parce que je me dise aimerait
créer donc je mets des sous de côté pour
payer la maison et pouvoir a laissé une
maison à mes deux enfants
sauf que là ça devient infernal pas ce
que je fais tes pmp le soir le matin je
dis vrai je deviens vraiment fait
vraiment vraiment fatigué est-ce que je
dois arrêter pmp ou est ce que je dois
arrêter le camion on va voir l'avis des
téléspectateurs j'ai ma petite idée
quand même est-ce que je sens que tu es
très ému dpeba même élan croissance
qu'est ce qui aurait motivé choisir
entre je croyais que ça allait plus
tranché que ça je vais en parler demain
avec mon patron je voir ce qu'il en
pense mais je pense que je vais
continuer tes pmp
[Applaudissements]